- Welcome to the show.
- This is awesome.
- Um, it is awesome.
Wait, have you ever met Ann before?
- No.
- Then it's even more awesome.
Yeah, you're a legend,
rockstar, this is the coolest.
- Oh, thank you very much.
- Yeah. If we have time,
I was wondering if we might play a few,
or start a band, or. I mean,
I know you're busy, but.
[kelly laughs]
- Well, yeah, but not today.
[Kelly laughs]
- Okay, great. We'll get the guitar.
- She likes a road trip.
If you offer up an Airstream travel,
like maybe she'll be into it.
- Um, So what kind of
kid were you growing up?
Were you like easy on
your mama? Just asking.
- No, I was a little
rambunctious, you know.
Got into theater, talking too much,
trying to make the other kids laugh.
pretty much anything for a laugh, yeah.
- That was like me as a kid,
we turned out all right.
- That was one of the
few moments I was sweet.
- Oh, so here you are as a
kid though, headed for school.
This is
- Yeah.
- First of all, I had a
Goonies lunchbox like that.
- Did you?
- I did.
- Oh my god, I want that picture.
- I was a huge Goonies fan.
- That's awesome.
But, um, were you into Rambo?
- Absolutely. Yeah.
Everything. Rambo, Indiana Jones,
- Love.
- Huge fan.
- I got to re-watch with
all my kids recently.
- Oh, really?
- So, fun.
- Do you let them watch anything?
Cause I could watch just about
anything when I was a kid.
- I do, and here's the reason why.
They don't really notice.
things slip by them like they did me.
But I will say, I watched
Goonies with them,
and I was like,
- That's a great one.
although it's a little scary.
- Well, not just as scary.
It's like,
I'm like they're around
the entertainment industry.
So they hear language and
I'm like, you can't curse
until you pay your bills.
- Right.
- Um, so that's the rule in my house.
Um, But, it's like, it was
kind of like, "Oh my God."
Like, "I watched this as a child.
Like it's like some of the
stuff that happened in it.
- Yeah.
- But they don't seem phased by it.
And I, I wasn't either.
So
- There was, we had a bunch of family
and friends over and
everybody was gonna watch It.
The original from like
- 1990
- Oh, hell no!
I haven't watched that now.
- See I was like six years old and I
begged my family to watch.
And they were like, no,
you gotta go to bed.
And all my cousins were
there and I was like
I'm not leaving.
I'm watching this movie.
[kelly gasps]
And I watched and I went
into a catatonic state
- Yeah.
- Of pure fear.
And then my dad, who's
a, a bit mischievous
uh, snuck around the
backyard with the It mask.
- Nope
- Nope.
- And knocked on the window
and scared the bejesus outta me.
- Nope
- I was never the same.
Yeah.
- So that for me was Freddie Kruger.
- Oh really? Great movie.
Because my brother's like a
decade older than me and he
they were watching and I was
like, I'm old enough too.
Whatever. And I got in there.
I will never sit on a water bed.
- No
- I will never like yeah.
Johnny death sucked
- To.
- Yeah.
- I was like, I was so scared.
I was scared to death
of cockroaches because have
the box and the, oh my God.
- The sweater to this day is still cool.
Terrifying. No, it is terrifying.
- Terrifying!
- In a cool way?
- When people dress up and
I'm like, I'm like Halloween
I'm like out with my kids,
like trick -or - treating.
- Yeah.
And I see someone dresses
that I'm like it get away
from me.
- Yeah, yeah yeah.
beat it.
- Yeah.
What would you beg your
parents to let you do when
you were a kid that maybe
you weren't supposed to
- Oh, Wear a minis skirt I guess.
- Oh
- and they always said no.
So, so I'd wear the long skirt
and then walk outside
of the house and roll
it up
- And roll it.
[Crowd Laughs]
- Um, so wait, I heard you
got a tattoo to remind you
what it means to be human.
So what's that tattoo?
- Oh, I got this tattoo
that, um, it's Savage.
the word I was reading this book sapiens
and it's about early man.
And I was thinking about how we're all
Well, nI'm naked, but
that's all apologies.
- But Hey, if I was naked,
like that, I'd post it too.
But, like I'm like, whatever.
- But I, I, I got this tattoo
to remind myself of, you know
just that we're all the same
human animal and, and uh
you know, stay in touch with
that, that, that part of us
that we're all the same.
And then, and then of
course a song came out
I guess that made, it, just
took it a different turn
and then it became this pop
culture thing that I was like
I didn't get it for that.
- I know.
But I love that.
Like I love because it's like what?
Like kids say, they're
like, oh, they're so Savage.
And they're always like
- Exactly.
And like you I'm
- Like 37, like I'm not a kid.
You should be saying
Savage bro like it's just
- Yeah, I know.
Which makes it way better.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- Now it's like, it's
I think it's pushing
me into like dad bond.
- Oh, like I love it.
That is not a dad bod,
just letting you know.
Um, so tell us, tell us
about tomorrow's all new
episode of New Amsterdam.
- Uh, We are coming to the end.
I think we have two episodes left.
- Okay.
- And, and we're building
to a great finale.
I'm I'm getting hitched on
the show, which is exciting.
- Okay.
- Um, and uh
- Make sure
- Yeah. Yeah
[laughs]
I hope so.
And uh, no, it's great.
All the kind of relationships
are coming to head.
People are getting married,
people are breaking up and uh
And you know, as you saw on the clip
I'm trying to get the hospital back
from someone who was ,uh, taking
it in the wrong direction.
- Yeah. I love it.